this is this is the last question i had
on here and
um and it actually kind of gets to that
very last super chat which jesse is
talking about can the average male
achieve the top 10 percent of wealth
okay so that was my
my last question was this was how can
men benefit from all of this like
understanding what we've what we've just
been talking about for the last hour and
a half right now
we know what the stats are we know what
the data is we know what the
we we can at least make some
prognostications as to what's coming
down the pipes right when we talk about
the morgan stanley
uh the rise of the she economy stuff uh
when we look at what's going on in the
the rise in the acceptability of like
marxism really you know in society right
that's through through the university
systems which by the way are
run by women because largely 77 78
of women 78 of the teachers you will
have in your lifetime
from preschool all the way up to
post-graduate school will be women
so when we look and we see like the
education systems where where
uh you know i i i think it was
interesting like when we were talking
about like all these
uh you know these riots that were going
on in 2020 and people pulling down
statues and now all this
you know antifa and everything and
they're people saying well you know
they're teaching this communism and this
marxism in this in the university it's
like yeah of course they are you know it
sounds like a good idea when you
realize how much we paid the female
teachers that are in those systems right
now
marxism probably sounds like a pretty
good idea to women who are already
predisposed
to communitarianism and egalitarianism
and you know emotionalism and everything
else
though yeah yeah exactly um so
mike my question is is that knowing all
of this and you know being on
being in the know i guess how can we how
can men benefit from this can the
average guy
become the top 10 percent of wealth i i
think so but
uh and i want to run down like sort of
four different little
you know issues here one of them is
protection and i think that rich
actually talks about this quite a bit is
like protecting your asset like what can
you do to sort of like if you're going
to get into
you know do you still want to like guys
still want to get laid guys still want
to
you know solve their reproductive
problem they still want to have kids
they still want to you know they still
want to get the girls aaron
no matter what the numbers say they
still want to get the girls
um so how can men like protect
themselves is it just
mgtow is marriage gonna change
completely um to the point where like
guys have to sort of like
you know have prenuptial agreements all
the time so that's the protection aspect
then also the rise of the she economy
knowing that women are going to be
uh let's say more like lonely but like
more empowered as far as economics are
concerned and directing where that money
is going in the future
how can you as a guy who is an
entrepreneur who is a guy who's
who understands this stuff how can you
benefit from that how can you make a how
can you turn a buck
as a result of that uh also maybe this
gets back to what aaron was talking
about in his book
which the point really uh correct me if
i'm wrong aaron but the point of writing
the book of numbers was to sort of make
guys
aware of the realities of the numbers
and the money that they are spending
when they are doing that in the pursuit
of women that's i believe that's the
subtitle of your book right
right yes it's basically a cost benefit
analysis
right the last the fourth part here
again benefiting is
housing real estate and expatriation uh
which is another thing we were talking
about rich is going to
at least i believe he has a year plan to
expatriate from
from canada george i know you don't
necessarily live in one place at one
time for very long so i don't know if
you're
technically an expat but i know that you
don't stay right
you're a rolling stone my friend um so
is that part of like benefiting
from this new environment that you guys
are aware of
yeah i mean rich i i retired in 2012.
i'm not sure when rich well rich is
still kind of in the game
and i have a lot of people ask me
entrepreneurial questions
and rich and i think are right around
the same age and i remember
when i first started my uh or first
started a business
you know you needed to have a hundred
thousand dollars you needed the last one
where i actually had to generate some
capital to start was in 2007 or
something we you know needed
500 000 uh just as a runway to get the
business going
and that business produced you know call
it we
grew it up to about 24 million in annual
revenues but what's amazing now
with uh what we have as far as the
internet and opportunities for us to
reach worldwide markets
is uh the barrier of entry is very very
low you don't have to have 500 thousand
dollars
anymore uh in order to build a business
that generates 24 million dollars
uh in in gross revenue you can do it you
can add value there's so many more
opportunities out there for young males
to make money than we had i'm assuming
all of us are pretty much the same age
growing up in the 1970s and the 1980s i
mean
way more opportunities way more
opportunities and not only that to make
money quickly uh to make a lot of money
quickly
i mean look at the kids that just
started the uh the fit and uh
fresh and fit uh isn't that the podcast
and look at their success look at those
guys that's what hustle will get you
and that's something that could not have
been possible i think i mean
those kids are are such hustlers they
would have done well regardless of what
do you call them kids i'm gonna
say i'm gonna link right to this moment
hey hey myron look at this you kid
but but seriously you know they're
they're they're they would do well
whatever they did in life
it wouldn't be a matter of if they're
going to be successful it would just be
a matter of when
they're exploiting the game they
understand the game well enough that
they can play it well
yeah but with the internet and with
youtube and with the uh
the ability to create content and to get
the word out
um you know you're able to to scale
much much faster much opportunity and
the risk reward
is far better today uh than it was
in my opinion by just going out and
borrowing 500 grand to start a brick and
mortar business
aaron how can they play the game better
how can we how can we benefit from this
let me count the ways that when you're
asking the categories i took some notes
this could be a little
a little linear here to capitalize
um i would go with female index funds
which i do believe would be coming
around
uh and i know it's it's the cheap shop
but it's true
i really believe egg freezing technology
or the chemicals associated with it
or you know media uh
something that benefits and we all ha ha
box whining cats i'm sure but
you know and a company that provides a
pet insurance you know
think so i would do that uh i would get
a vasectomy
unless you're absolutely sure you want
to have kids and even if you have
vasectomy you can also
uh have a direct extraction which you
don't want to know the process
um never marry would be another
uh defensive move on and in terms of
hedging against inflation and
maintaining your wealth
silver crypto i call it a plan b
uh which george is familiar with where
you got to make aims to
be able to leave the united states or
canadore or western nation and go to
where
they're not going to confiscate in
riches case 53
of your labor time and effort and energy
or if they just
come after you um so that's a
that's a and that's a task that requires
travel and all that
i would also hedging against inflation
is major in stem or some
other valuable skill because your skills
are not only transferable but they are a
natural hedge against inflation
a dentist just has to jack up their
price um a mechanic just has to jack up
their price a professional [ __ ] like
me i just jack up my
price uh make sure that you have skills
that are that are indispensable
and then finally more philosophically
insist on being a superior
person workout diet major in the right
thing
participate in hobbies make sure your
life counts i know we focus on money but
i'm a little bit more of a minimalist
philosopher and
and i focus more on time than anything
else i'd recommend being part of the
1099 superior race meaning being
self-employed
your life is too short to be answering
to a boss and you are
too precious to have your your you know
a third at least if you look at profit
margins on labor productivity
if not half of your worth paid out to a
corporation
to enrich your employer um i also would
advocate
minimalism although i know rich and
george with their fancy cars probably
would disagree but
i would put more generally
philosophically more valuable
value on time than money uh
and then finally this is the important
one and this this
is where 80 of the people um
fail and that is you f up you screw up
don't get a girl pregnant
don't major in something stupid don't
buy a car you can't afford
don't smoke uh and eat unhealthy and
play video games
like you know don't commit crime which i
don't think we'll have to worry about
this listening audience but if you look
at the vast majority of successful
people
and by success i mean they're not you
know let's say upper middle income or
or higher they didn't screw up they may
not have a
a doctorate in physics they may not have
a multi-million dollar empire
but they didn't screw up and so that is
something i think everybody can do along
with minimalism and all that to kind of
take advantage of of this future and and
it's been in rich's book
it's in my it's put yourself first
make sure you're the best person you
could be because at the absolute
worst you will have not wasted your life
oh and finally one other thing
i i forgot this uh give up your dreams
because it wouldn't be me if it wasn't a
little dick
i don't care how much you love the girls
i don't care how much you want wifey
kids
now is not your time if you get it great
but
do not pine and hope and hinge your
happiness on that
because it is out of your control
yeah what about coin collecting aaron
you know y'all cool enough to be coined
what about stamps or stamps cool can i
have a stamp collection uh
yeah you could collect stamps um all
right so
i'm i'm gonna co-sign everything that's
uh both aaron and george said i can't
disagree with anything
um i just wanted to put this up here
real quick he says can the average male
achieve the top 10 percent wealth uh i'm
gonna say
no if you're defining yourself as
average average people don't do
extraordinary
things okay you need to take yourself
out of the average category
there's a lot of average people out
there average people don't put dents in
the universe they might put a little
you know something in it but they're not
going to do anything dramatic
um it has never been easier to make
money
ever in the history of humankind yeah
and one of the things that drives me
absolutely insane is when guys complain
rich says you need to be a millionaire
by the time you're this age
okay why does it why does it piss these
guys off
because they see themselves as average
they see it as an impossible feat a
million dollars is not hard to make
there are trillions of dollars traveling
through the internet
every second of every day even on the
weekends
okay all you gotta do is put something
out there and grab something
solve a problem okay product service
something with recurring revenue
there's any number of things that you
can do to grab a little bit of that
piece of the pie
what does money do it solves problems it
allows you to apply
a store of value to problems in your
life and solve them
if you're an average guy and you're
stuck in a mediocre part of the world
and you don't have access to financial
resources it's very hard to change
your environment okay one of the things
that uh aaron and george didn't
touch on was maneuver go where you're
treated better
if there's a place that taxes you lower
that's something that you can consider
if there's a place with a more favorable
climate that you'd enjoy
that's something to consider if there's
a place with more
attractive feminine agreeable women
that's something else that you can
consider columbia don't have to stay
where you're at
you can pick up and move traveling
around the world is very very easy have
more than one passport
if you can get two or three passports um
through
your parents or your grandparents on
both sides maternal paternal
you have an ability to like if the
canadian government says to me
fu i'm going to take away your passport
cool no problem i've got two other
european passports i can still travel
i'm not
limited to move around borders aren't
going to stop me from doing what i want
to do
put yourself first you know the whole
coin phrase
rolotomasi uses mental point of origin
put your damn self first and i and and
and get very very clear get laser
focused on the kind of life that you
want to live because like aaron said
it moves fast it like time will fly
you'll never be able to make more time
you can always make more money you can
start up something that sucks collapses
on itself and blows up
and two years later you could be the
bee's knees again
um i can't remember the guy's name but
the two guys that founded
instagram turned around and sold it
three years after they started it for a
billion dollars to facebook with 12
employees
i'm not saying that that's repeatable
for all you guys out there
but don't think for a minute that making
money is impossible
it's not yeah
i'll just throw my two cents in here is
uh i co-signed everything everybody else
has said here of course
um and and more to riches point um i've
had it explain to me
like this is that there is a river of
money out there and all you have to do
is figure out how to divert
some of that river to your little farm
and
in today's you know high-tech you know
internet what i've called the new order
in my uh in my fourth book here
in today's information society it has
never been easier to figure that out on
your own
um as these guys are saying it's never
been easier to make money it's just
the the the lack of creative
intelligence the lack of trying to
like of i don't know we'll say
innovation but being
clever enough to do so um the other part
that i
i have to also throw in there is it's uh
resist the lure of easing up on your
focus
um if you're sedated by something
whether that's pornography whether
that's alcohol whether that's drugs
whether that's opiates whether that's
video games whatever it is you are
sedated at some point by
something and it's important to get
unsedated from that because you will
never reach your potential as long as
you are sedated in fact
this especially for men right now for
women
uh what is it rich was saying uh you
know women are told uh you know
you do what's right for you girl and for
men they're told to do what's
correct me if i'm wrong i think i got
this right men are told to
do the right thing while women are told
to do what's right for them
and i think that uh that that's a that's
a good
illustration of how we expect certain
things from guys
and do not put on or do not keep the uh
the same
don't hold the same kind of ideals that
you think you ought to have because
that's the way you've been conditioned
by the blue pill
okay so that's that's that and then um
last but not least is go read robert
greene's mastery okay it has never been
easier to master something than now
um whether that's you know it used to be
that you had to go find a master
and become an apprentice and and you
know spend ten thousand hours to become
a master at something and now you can go
on youtube and learn how to hang drywall
if that's what you want to do
lord knows aaron probably built his
entire new house you don't even want to
know
what uh yeah i'm practically a master
carpenter right now yes
yeah you learn how to how do i carpet my
house right there's there's probably a
video for that uh how do i clean my gun
how do i
fish how do i tie a tie for christ's
sake okay
those kind of things it's not hard to
find that it's never been easier to be a
master at something we've never had this
kind of
you know ease of access to that kind of
stuff but yet we've never been
lazier because you've been sedated by
something
so yeah you're sedated by and get away
from that sedation because you will not
become
you know above average like what does it
take to become to go from ordinary to
extraordinary you'll never find out
if you are weighted down with the
sandbags of being sedated by something
you